se nos pregunta que es igual a que es
igual 10 a la quinta potencia 10 a la
quinta potencia eso es lo mismo que
tomar 1 esto es igual a 1 y
multiplicarlo por 10 5 veces entonces 1
por 10 x 10 x 10 x 10 y por 10 tenemos 1
por 1 2 3 4 5 10 es ya que será igual
esto veamos 1 por 10 es igual a 10 y 10
por 10 es igual a 100 100 por 10 es
igual a 1000 mil por 10 es igual a 10
mil y 10 mil por 10 es igual a 100.000
así que esto será igual a 100.000
excelente entonces tal vez tú ya no
estás te que cada vez que multiplicó por
10 estamos agregando otro 0 al producto
entonces si estamos multiplicando por 10
5 veces tenemos uno seguido de cinco
ceros aquí lo puedes ver hay cinco ceros
esto será igual a literalmente será
igual a uno acá también tenemos uno
seguido de 5
05 01 22 34 50 entonces 10 en la quinta
potencia es igual a 10.000 hagamos otro
ejemplo similar aquí dice cuántos ceros
tiene el producto 67 por 10 a la quinta
potencia hay varias maneras de hacer
esto podemos decir que 67 por 10 a la
quinta potencia es igual ok esto lo
podemos ver como 67 multiplicado por lo
que ya hicimos antes en el ejemplo
anterior es la misma lógica entonces 67
x 10 x 10 x 10 x 10 y por 10 y ya
sabemos a que será igual esto es cierto
ya sabemos el resultado de esta parte
tenemos que esto esto es igual a 1
seguido de 50 uno dos tres cuatro cinco
ceros o 100.000 así que hay varias
maneras de hacer los hilos si no miras
como en este producto puedes pensar 67
por 1 es igual a 67 y cada vez que
multiplicas por un 10 agregar a otro 0
entonces esto será igual
7 y como vamos a estar multiplicando por
10 5 veces vamos a agregarle cinco ceros
uno dos tres cuatro cinco ceros ahí está
así que la respuesta es 6.700.000 otra
manera esto es lo mismo que 67% mil así
que 67 y como tenemos 50 cent 100 mil
vamos a agregar cinco ceros al 67
así que obtenemos exactamente lo mismo
hagamos otro aquí dice cuántos ceros
tiene el cociente 5.700.000 dividido
entre 10 a la tercera potencia muy bien
sabemos que 10 a la tercera potencia
esto es igual a 1 por 10 x 10 x 10
entonces esto es igual ya sabemos que es
igual a 1000 y como vamos a dividir
entre 1000 esta expresión puede ser
escrita como o de la siguiente manera
tenemos aquí 5.700.000
dividido entre 10 a la tercera potencia
esto es exactamente lo mismo que
5.700.000 sobre 10 x 10 x 10 pero como
el 1 aquí no importa si lo pongo no
cambia el producto así que no lo voy a
poner y eso es lo mismo que 5.700.000
dividido entre 1000 cuál sea la manera
que pienses en esto cada vez que
divididas entre 10 eliminarás uno de
estos ceros así que si divides entre 10
3 veces si divides entre 10 una vez se
va un cero en el siguiente 10 otro 0 y
en el último 10 otro 0 ahí tienes que se
fueron tres ceros entonces el resultado
de 5.700 otra manera de hacerlo es
pensar que si estoy dividiendo entre
algo que tiene tres ceros voy a eliminar
tres ceros entonces se van tres ceros y
me quedan cinco mil setecientos ahora
bien esto lo puede hacer porque estoy
dividiendo entre 1000 pero si esto fuera
por ejemplo 3000
entonces yo podría pensar en esto como 3
por 1000 cancelaría estos 3 ceros pero
tendría que hacer la división entre 3
por separado así que esto en este caso
fue directo porque estoy dividiendo
entre 1000 o lo que es lo mismo entre
una potencia de 10 pero por eso yo puedo
cancelar estos ceros pero si no tendría
que ser la división completa hagamos
unos cuantos más ejemplos entonces aquí
dice cuando 72.1 es multiplicado por 10
a la tercera potencia el punto decimal
se mueve espacio lugares a la espacio
hay que llenar ese espacio entonces
recuerda que si estás multiplicando por
en este caso estamos multiplicando por
1000 vas a obtener un número mayor y no
lo contrario no menor sino mayor cada
vez que multiplicadas por ti es el punto
decimal se moverá hacia la derecha 72.1
si lo multiplicas por 10 una vez
entonces por ejemplo que hay aquí
volveríamos el punto decimal a la
derecha una vez así que se va una vez a
la derecha si lo multiplicamos por 10
tres veces no sólo moveremos el punto
decimal
a la derecha sino tres veces entonces
una seria sería una vez dos veces y tres
veces y si piensas ok pero yo como puedo
poner aquí espacio si no tengo nada
simplemente llenas con cero y ya así de
sencillo así que la respuesta será
72.100 pero nos están preguntando eso
quieren saber cuántos espacios se está
moviendo a la que se moverá tres a la
derecha ya lo hicimos así que entonces
hagamos el siguiente ejercicio dice
cuando 56 es dividido entre 10 la
tercera potencia el punto decimal se
mueve espacio lugares a la espacio así
que dividir entre 10 a la tercera
potencia es lo mismo que dividir entre
10 3 veces y cada vez que divididas
entre 10 se hará el número más pequeño
entonces 56 donde donde queda el punto
decimal ahí implícitamente está aquí
entonces ok si divido entre 10 una vez
se mueve una vez a la izquierda en este
caso si divido entre 10 otra vez se
mueve otro espacio y me queda punto 56
y si divido entre 10 una tercera vez
aquí pongo un 0 se mueve tres veces a la
izquierda y ya tenemos la respuesta
sería puntos 0 56 ahí pongo el punto así
que punto 0 56 y de hecho puedo poner el
crucero para que quede un poco más claro
movimos el decimal tres lugares entonces
tres lugares a la izquierda en este caso
y ya nos vemos